para la cuarta ronda de audiencias
públicas del comité del 6 de enero la
atención se puso sobre los funcionarios
estatales a quienes donald trump y sus
aliados presionaron repetidamente para
que certificaran la victoria de joe
biden basándose en las teorías
conspirativas de fraude electoral el
bando republicano de trump sabía que
eran falsas trump fue informado por sus
propios asesores de que no tenía ninguna
base para sus afirmaciones de elecciones
robadas y siguió presionando a los
funcionarios estatales para que
cambiaran los resultados en el punto de
mira a arizona donde el presidente de la
cámara de representantes del estado
rasti powers recibe una llamada de tram
y su ex abogado rubí giuliani afirmando
falsamente que miles de migrantes
ilegales y personas muertas habían
votado por you why del más tarde la
bogotá de trump john eastman estaba uers
a descertificar a los electores de su
estado al choque nou y volvió a decir
que hice un juramento para mí hacer eso
hacer lo que ustedes hacen sería
contrario a mi juramento magos también
testificaron funcionarios del estado de
georgia incluido el secretario de estado
a quien trump pidió que encontrara los
11 mil 780 votos necesarios para superar
el total de byd en muchos de los que
subieron al estado y relataron una
campaña de acoso
tras el blanco de trump por su negativa
a anular la elección incluyendo una
trabajadora electoral de georgia y a su
madre
un montón de amenazas deseando la muerte
para mí diciéndome en que ya sabes estar
en la cárcel con mi madre y diciendo
cosas como alégrate de que sea 2020 y no
frank e incluso trató de convencer a los
funcionarios estatales de que aprobaran
listas de falsos electores un intento
desesperado de aferrarse al cargo
haciendo temblar los cimientos de la
democracia estadounidense al amenazar el
traspaso pacífico del poder el comité
plantea al menos dos audiencias públicas
más ya que el departamento de justicia
de eeuu debe decidir ahora si presenta o
no cargos penales contra el ex
presidente